now I do want to be clear there is no
single one right answer as long as
you're separating your concerns
so rather than compare my code to yours
instead look at how my code is organized
and draw inspiration from that now to
start out I'll show you my index.html
file this is very simple I have a ul
called catalyst and a div with an ID of
cat it has a cat named cat count and cat
image inside of it
these things are things that the view is
going to hook onto and update whenever
it's being told to render let's dive
into the JavaScript now first we'll take
a look at the model now in this case the
model is simply an object literal with
current cat set to null and cats being
this very large array of objects each
one of these objects represents a cat
and inside of each of these cats
I've got clicked count name image source
and image attribution now let's scroll
down and take a look at our octopus in
our octopus I have the init method which
starts off the entire application I also
have a get current cat and get cat
function the view calls both of those in
order to get the current cat or all of
the cats so that way you can render
properly we also have a set current cat
function you pass it in object and it
sets the current cat equal to the object
that you pass in and lastly we have
increment counter what that does is it
takes our current cat and it increments
its click count now whenever that
happens it tells the cat view to render
let's take a quick look at our view
before we see the flow of the
application first we have the cat view
the cat view is an object with an init
function and a render function I've
separated these out so that way I can
render it whenever I want to but in it
only gets called once for example I
don't want to grab all of these Dom
elements from the Dom every single time
we render I may as well just do it once
and store them here on the cat view
similarly I only want to add the click
listener for the cat view once
now the reason is because as I click
between cats over here in index.html it
just changes this information here it
does not replace the entire div this div
is always here and this image element is
always
so I can add the event listener one time
and then no matter what cat I changed to
these elements will always be the same
they'll just have differing content and
a source attribute and lastly in our cat
view init method we call this dot render
which will update the view
what does render do all it does is it
gets our current cat from the octopus
which of course gets it from the model
and then we set the count element and
the name and the image to the click
count and the name and the image source
of our current cat remember that these
on the left hand are the Dom elements so
that's our cat ListView render gets
called over and over and over again but
in it only gets called once we'll see
where that gets called in just a moment
let's take a look at our cat ListView
our cat ListView is actually a bit
simpler here we have our init method
which only gets called once we grab the
cat list element from the Dom and put it
in this variable here and then we say
render ourselves let's see what render
does we first get the cats from the
octopus which of course originally we'll
get it from the model then we MDR ul
which lists all the cats and then we go
over all of the cat objects and we
create an Li and we do all of the
necessary stuff that being setting the
text content equal to the name of the
cat and adding an event listener now
here's my little closure trick that I
had to do in order to make this event
listener inside the for-loop work and
you'll find that this is a common thing
that you'll have to do if you're adding
event listeners inside of a for loop you
actually need to create a larger
function pass in your cat and then
return the function which does the stuff
that you want with that cat so
ultimately all of this code says when
you click on the element tell the
octopus to set the current cat and then
render the cat view because it's changed
and lastly add all of our allies inside
of this for loop that we've created to
our cat list elem the unordered list of
cats now let's run through this really
fast
octopus dot in it this makes everything
happen when this gets called the
following things happen we say hey model
set your current cat property equal to
model cats zero
in other words the first cat in the list
and then we say cat listview in it and
cat view dot in it we tell our views to
initialize themselves and then the views
handle all the stuff they need to do
without the octopus needing to get
involved now if you'd like to go over
this code you can find a link to it in
the instructor notes I would definitely
suggest you dive in and see if you can
figure out exactly how every part of
this works then compare it to your code
if you want to go back to your code and
make any changes go ahead and do that
now but don't copy my code remember this
is not my project this is your project
so only use my code as organizational
inspiration once you're satisfied with
your version of cat clicker premium go
ahead and click to continue on